[Musica]
io sono qui oggi per parlarvi per
parlarvi di che cos'è un umanista anche
se avessi saputo che sente l'intervento
di chiara probabilmente l'avrei
preparato un po diverso il mio visto che
ha dato uno straordinario esempio di
quello che adesso vi dirò
proviamo a fare un gioco allora se io
chiedo ognuno di voi di esprimere
un'opinione incalzando la mano rispetto
a questa frase cioè una frase interiore
un po come quella che nasce dal profondo
di cui parlava chiara cioè tendo a
cercare la purezza quanti di voi sono
d'accordo con questa affermazione di
principio io alzo la mano ma che sono
d'accordo abbastanza oppure tendo a
cercare l'uguaglianza ancora tendo a
conoscere me stesso sono tutte frasi
facilmente condivisibili no sono frasi
che attengono a una dimensione della
filosofia che si chiama ontologia
l'ontologia è proprio la parte della
filosofia che tende verso la scoperta di
ciò che è vero e riguarda quel profondo
tentativo di immergersi in noi stessi di
cui chiara ha fatto un grandissimo
affresco se questi stessi concetti li
prova a declinare in una frase che a
questo punto non è più una bolla di
pensiero ma è un affermazione in ambito
più che altro sociale cioè dico è giusto
voler essere puri oppure è giusto essere
uguali o ancora è giusto conoscere se
stessi
probabilmente gli stessi che hanno
alzato la mano prima si farebbero la
domanda è si chiederebbero se è
opportuno a questo punto condividere
ancora questo senso di giustizia
applicata questi principi sacrosanti di
tipo ontologico quando comunque affermo
un valore teorico e cerco questo valore
teorico di affermarlo come principio di
giustezza sto facendo quella che nella
filosofia si chiama etica e l'etica
cerca proprio il giusto la terza grande
e fondamentale sfera della filosofia
invece l'estetica che trasforma per
astrazione questi stessi concetti i
principi generali cioè la vita e purezza
la vita e uguaglianza o ancora la vita e
conoscere se stessi
vedete che qui ritorno
una sorta di leggerezza perché qui è più
facile condivide l'estetica è quella
parte della filosofia che tende a
definire diciamo il bello come senso
ultimo della vita l'esperienza che ha
raccontato chiara che continua a
strumentalizzare è perfetta perché lei
ha raccontato la bellezza della
dimensione estetica della sua stessa
esistenza al suo viaggio esistenziale è
stato raccontato in modo devo dire
straordinario molto emozionante
ora non immaginate che queste tre sfere
debbano essere colte come tre passaggi
conseguenti l'uno all'altro ma piuttosto
come tre vasi uno dentro l'altro il
primo vaso e quello dell'ontologia ed è
l'antologia una dimensione assoluta
perché avete abbastanza evidenza del
fatto che quando ognuno di un e morirà
la storia per me che sono morto è finita
è finita la storia dell'umanità per me
fino a prova contraria
per me che sono morto e quindi in chiave
antologica la dimensione della mia
interiorità è un assoluto però quando io
mi relaziono con l'altro e cerco di
finire nella relazione con l'altro ciò
che è giusto e ciò che non lo è mi
accorgo che anche l'altro è assoluto e
quando io che sono assoluto un incontro
con un'altra persona anch'essa assoluta
mi rendo conto che per lui io sono
relativo tuttavia superata la dialettica
che io sono per gioco necessitato a fare
nel rapporto con gli altri
entro questo punto nella dimensione
estetica il ritrovo l'assoluto quello
che gli antichi chiamavano il bello
assoluto dipende proprio da questa
caratteristica fondamentale
dell'estetica e cioè la ricerca è un po
come l'artista che davanti alla tela
bianca è libero di fare ciò che vuole
quindi l'opera è lì e libera espressione
del proprio genio al suo massimo
splendore quando ci si riesce
ecco sono tre fasi vasi comunicanti da
importante concepirli così perché quando
ognuno di noi sente un istinto interiore
in chiaro antologica e non lo coglie
lo compie come tale cioè se io cerco la
purezza dentro di me e non la colgo
dentro di me ma la trasporto la si
direbbe
l'us posto nella dimensione etica e
faccio questo spostamento rischio che
l'ontologia che è assoluta faccia
diventare assoluta anche l'etica e
questa piccolissima cosa che spero di
essere riuscito a chiarire è il motivo
per cui abbiamo vissuto drammi
straordinari
durante il secolo scorso e non soltanto
nella storia dell'uomo per intero che è
fatta così
parlavo di purezza se io dico è giusto
essere puri cosa facciamo con chi
secondo me non è puro
e qui che nasce vedete l'etica assoluta
che produce i drammi che abbiamo
conosciuto e se dico è giusto essere
uguali cosa faccio con quelli che si
credono diversi con quelle persone che
rappresentano simbolicamente la
vocazione alla discendenza divina per
nascita e che devono essere uccisi
quando nasce il comunismo
questo è lo zero ovviamente per poter
affermare l'idea del siamo tutti uguali
per quello che rappresentano
e così che nascono le tic e assolute che
hanno distrutto tantissime cose tra cui
anche la cultura la famosa e
fondamentale cultura la cultura umanista
nel secolo scorso
perché vi parlo di questi argomenti
perché oggi si parla di tecnologia si
parla di innovazione e oggi il futuro
che stiamo scrivendo e sempre di più
fatto da algoritmi e l'algoritmo è
proprio un pezzo di etica assoluta
perché basata su 0 e 1 non conosci grigi
un pezzo di etica embè data dentro un
codice di programma e gli algoritmi sono
quelli che decidono tutto della nostra
vita perché decidono che libri leggere
dobbiamo leggere per aumentare la nostra
capacità di cultura chi dobbiamo sposare
probabilmente per un affinità di coppia
che gli algoritmi saranno un giorno in
grado di decidere molto meglio di quanto
possiamo fare noi stessi e noi ci
fideremo cosa mangiare perché il nostro
sistema le analisi
il sangue blu verranno elaborate da un
algoritmo e ci dirà che cosa è giusto
mangiare per non ingrassare o per
digerire meglio
eccetera eccetera tutto è così e pensate
per esempio alla macchina che si guida
da sola
statisticamente è già stato quasi
provato almeno in principio teorico che
la macchina che si guida da sola
attraverso algoritmi è in grado di fare
meno danni di quanto ovviamente non
possa fare un essere umano quando sale
sulla propria automobile
se accettiamo questo perché è giusto
ecco il fatto etico inventato nell'albo
ritmo è giusto dare il primato alla
sicurezza noi smettiamo di farci la
domanda fondamentale e cioè se vi
chiedessi adesso di raccontarmi ognuno
di voi
la cosa più importante la storia più
incredibile che via successa nella
vostra esistenza fino ad oggi
probabilmente nel 99 per cento dei casi
sarebbero errori sarebbero dolori
sarebbero tutto ciò che non è efficienza
e pure ontologicamente posso dire che le
io aspiro all'efficienza ma eticamente
se affermo è giusto essere efficienti
cancello una dimensione praticamente che
la dimensione dell'essere umano che
l'algoritmo non può assolutamente
contemplare e quindi bisogna riprendere
ed è con questo che vi lascio bisogna
riprendere a mio avviso il percorso
della cultura umanista ecco che cos'è un
grande umanista grande umanista e con il
quale non dimentica da dove veniamo
proposito di profondità rientrare nella
profondità della grande cultura umanista
significa riprendere chi come eraclito
parmenide aveva già detto tutto questo
aveva già capito tutto ed è lo strumento
fondamentale per affrontare la
tecnologia e la rivoluzione tecnologica
che ci aspetta si direbbe che l'italia
il paese
naturalmente migliore per poter
rispondere a questa grande sfida perché
noi siamo intrisi dalla cultura umanista
da sempre l'abbiamo proprio nel nostro
codice genetico nella nostra identità
eppure credo che tutto quello che ho
raccontato sia distante anni luce dal 99
per cento degli italiani e non lo dico
con cattiveria dico che l'italia
un protagonismo ma non è un'identità
necessariamente dell'italiano quella di
essere un umanista e come se fosse un
piatto tipico italiano
l'essere umanista bisogna però a saperlo
cucinare avere umiltà imparare quali
sono gli ingredienti come assemblarli e
per finire questo sono io che mangio un
altro piatto tipico italiano grazie
mille
[Musica]